we're on our way to dap chi a remote
town in Nigeria's northeastern nuba
state dap she has largely been spared
from attacks by Boko Haram jihadists but
that ended this week when armed
militants stormed the local school
dozens of school girls are now missing
this is the hostel where some of the
students were staying before the attack
right now it's deserted classes are
suspended we meet Jambu ma Heat her
daughter Zara has been missing for days
she shows us all visitors cards from the
school as well as a picture of her
daughter the whole family is in despair
this yeah I'm sorry you see I am we
looked everywhere in and around town and
couldn't find her must have kidnapped
her yeah most parents believe that Boko
Haram took their children witnesses say
they saw girls riding on a track that
drove out of the city parents have put
together the names of 105 missing girls
the government hasn't released any
official numbers or any information on
where the girls could be we've been
given no information about our children
first the governor tells us they've been
rescued then he comes back and says no
one will be rescued
the town of dap she is still in a state
of shock and waiting for the government
to act on its promise of a rescue
mission